what up guys today i am going to react
to this youtube channel called
alpha male strategies it says why women
go back to men
who lie or cheat and if it ain't broken
don't fix it i can't imagine this video
is gonna be a feel-good video that makes
me
feel good about myself and like the
world is a
good place
yikes anyways let me know
um in the comments if you agree or
disagree also let me know what i should
react to
next time and don't forget to like
comment and subscribe
also follow my instagram which is in the
description
i'm gonna do like polls on my instagram
of like what videos we should be react
to
and do like submissions there so follow
my instagram this is really important
i'm trying to get to like 10 000 on
there so
i'm just trying to keep you guys
included in my goals you feel me
i'm getting tired i'm not even gonna lie
okay this might be my last one for the
night
what's up fellas so today we're here to
talk about
why women come back after you lie cheat
and disrespect them
all right guys so this is gonna go to my
point of what i've been saying
you guys must get through your [ __ ]
head
that women love turmoil
women are not sane guys can i get that
through y'all
women are emotional women do not want to
be with your boring ass
sitting on the couch watching seinfeld
reruns
eating popcorn all right get that
through your [ __ ] heads
that's why y'all guys get that speech i
need space
women get tired of your boring ass all
right
i will say that at some point
women get tired of the toxic ones i know
a lot of you are gonna think i'm crazy
i know in the comments you're gonna
disagree with me but uh
some like i've heard a lot of girls just
say like i just want someone nice after
they've dated a couple toxic guy like
i've seen a lot of friends get out of
toxic relationships and find a nice guy
to marry women love turmoil in their
life
now here's the thing before you guys
think i'm going to just
start going out here lying and cheating
and disrespecting my woman on my women
because a message the most creative
turmoil
well please believe you must create the
attachment first
so guys you seeing that are able to do
this and women come back to them
that's because they have an attachment
to that guy
now how did that guy get that attachment
he makes her feel
a certain type of way when she's with
him
more than likely very feminine all right
guys
so he's probably at acting very
masculine alright so that's the thing
with that guys
you guys have got to learn to build an
attachment after that
lying and cheating we will actually
create
more of attachment all right because
you're creating
turmoil ask yourself this which one you
think will create more of an attachment
being honest and bringing flowers to a
woman and telling you love her
or hanging out with your homeboys for
two or three days where you disappear
don't answer a phone call
and then when you do answer it you go
there and you [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of and
you know how to make her feel a certain
type of weight
which one you think isn't there an
option three
isn't there an option
he's talking about pushovers but
you don't have to be a push-up
i'm just going to keep watching the
video like no no sorry
he's talking about [ __ ] pushover
there's a middle ground
fellas well the guy who's disappears for
two or three days
now before you guys go out there and
just disappear for two or three or four
or five days
the one of you get the guys that you got
in relationships and
thinking that oh and it's going to
create the attachment no
it's the way you make a woman feel when
you with her
that the the days you disappear actually
matter don't mean
[ __ ] if she don't actually get a feeling
from you
all right so i don't want you guys going
out here lying and cheating and
disrespecting your woman
and they ain't gonna disappear before
you even have no [ __ ] woman all right
you need to work on the attachment first
but after you have built the attachment
pre you can [ __ ] her goddamn mama
and she'll [ __ ] and she'll complain and
she might answer your phone call for a
couple days
but after where you you know we y'all
guys know not to pursue a woman i
always let her come back to you in a way
but she might don't reach out and call
you for a couple days
but she'll come around all right guys
and that's how
you do it that's why guys who lie and
cheat the women that's why they always
go back to them
women get tired i'm telling you
young women because here's the
difference between men and women when
women
start dating and having options they are
young
and so we don't have the wisdom or the
blinders to see
past things because
you're young right and dumb and whatever
but there becomes a time where you want
stability and you want a stable
relationship and you want like a happy
home and that doesn't come
from marrying someone that lies and
cheats it only works if you built the
[ __ ] attachment alright guys
now the thing is guys
is you get a woman attached to
chasing your validation that is the
thing
all right women need that from you
if you have if you have built it she's
addicted to chasing your validation
because you don't
give it to her all right guys if you
don't give a woman your validation when
you're with her and
your masculine frame and [ __ ] she's
addicted to getting your validation
that is the thing guys that's why i tell
you guys do not give women your
compliments
of course if you guys disappear for two
or three days y'all guys know you have
to you know feed women scraps and [ __ ]
like this
this is going to be a case in point of a
guy who definitely has to feed women
scraps
because a guy that lie cheating stealing
[ __ ] like this
a woman like that is going to be bring a
lot of emotional baggage to the
relationship
and so he's gonna have to calm that down
with feeding women scraps
all right for all you nice guys i don't
that want to compliment women
and classify it as feeding scraps is
[ __ ] it only matters in a situation
like
feeding what's what's feeding scraps i
don't get it it's
to wear a guy who's creating turmoil in
women's life
all right guys y'all guys got to get
that through your [ __ ] head
all right i don't drip that drip that
i'm hoping i'm dripped that enough guys
this is what women need in the
relationship women need
uncertainty all right all right and the
next thing is and this is a big point i
want to have my own too guys
we need uncertainty
i'm trying to think if that's true
i don't i just from what i've seen
women want uncertainty to a certain age
then they realize
oh i have to get married this guy
probably wouldn't be a good
guy to raise my kids i'm going to pick
someone who's going to be a good father
i swear half these guys don't want to
get married anyway so
they don't care because i had another
guy come on and say uh
well his family members compliment women
all the time and it works so
one thing before i say anything else
guys i won't let you guys know if
something is working for you
then keep doing it but i want you guys
to know something
my channel is not about
you can't compliment women my channel is
about improving
your closing rate all right i want you
guys to understand that
yes you can compliment women and [ __ ]
women yes you can validate women
and [ __ ] women yes you can go on a date
and be a dancing monkey i did all that
[ __ ] [ __ ]
and i [ __ ] plenty of women all right yes
you can be overweight and [ __ ] women
yes you can be broke and [ __ ] women but
we all know if you're fit
and you're successful you're going to
get more options
all right so my channel guys is about
[ __ ] more
[ __ ] it's not about oh if you
compliment a woman you ain't gonna [ __ ]
no [ __ ] no no no you can go out there
and you can compliment women
you can do all that [ __ ] [ __ ] but
what i'm saying is
my guys are gonna [ __ ] more girls than
you
i can't say this is the feel-good
youtube video i was hoping for
why do you guys recommend these why do
you do this to me
why i better get a lot of views on this
video
sacrificing my mental health
i'm gonna think every guy i talk to
cheats on me i swear to god
i'm gonna be like crazy by the end of
the series
that's what i'm saying so i want y'all
guys to get that straight for any guy
that's on here to think like
well i'm i know a fat guy that [ __ ] what
i'm saying is if that fat guy was in
shape he would [ __ ] even
more women all right for any of you guys
that are on here saying
i know a broke guy that don't got [ __ ]
and he got plenty of girls what i'm
saying is if that guy had his [ __ ]
together
he would [ __ ] even more women all right
guys
so that's what my channel about my
channel is not about my way
of the highway and if you don't do it
this way you ain't gonna [ __ ] no girls
that's not what i'm saying guys
i don't [ __ ] plenty of women in the
class uh
joking around and you know i what i'm
telling you what i
found out holding a masculine frame and
not validating women and giving women
uncertainty
is far better than giving women
certainty and complimenting them yeah
you gonna [ __ ] some women
but you just not gonna have the same
closing rate as
when i complimented women and i did all
that [ __ ] guys my closing rate was about
thirty to forty percent
right do you guys get like even if
you wear protection
you still can transmit like hpv
like okay nevermind never
why worry about all right so if i want
10 dates i will [ __ ] three or four of
them
i wanted that to improve i tell you guys
over and over again
i started really studying game to
improve my closing rate because i felt
like it should be higher than what it
was
in one day i went get no ass i just
wanted to [ __ ]
mo [ __ ] that's what my [ __ ] about so
when i got into it i started noticing
[ __ ] that i would do
and i said man my closing rate goes up
went up now it's about if i go on 10
days i'll [ __ ] at least seven of those
girls
which means that my closing rate almost
doubled
all right so that's the thing guys i was
out i was [ __ ] [ __ ]
complimenting women and all that [ __ ]
what i'm telling you is that
it and also another thing i noticed also
too
is that women pursue me now
all right that's another thing back in
the day they would always
pull back and stuff like so do the girls
watch these like cheating videos and
they're like oh
sign me up for that that'll get cold
from time to time
maybe they don't disappear all together
but they would pull back and sometimes
they win
set days and this that another now these
girls are kidding me up
like hey am i going to see you this
weekend which is what you want you want
women chasing you
it used to be hey are you free this
weekend and
uh well my mama gonna bring the dog by
and uh can i get back with you and yeah
i can still [ __ ] that girl
but you don't want no response like that
you want a woman chasing your validation
you want a woman if you if first of all
most of the girls i fool with guys that
are in my rotation they ask me
are they going to see me this weekend or
when the next time i'ma see
you all right that's what you want so
i'm to the point now well
if there's a woman that's in my rotation
she pretty much asking when she's going
to see me
now that don't happen with girls i'm
just now starting with just not dating
but once a girl's in my rotation like
after a month or something like that
she's asking me which is what you want
which puts you in the driver's seat
all right guys so that's how it's done
and this is also how you get a woman's
soul guys
we're about getting souls over here i'm
beyond
getting laid lane was is so early 2000s
late we want souls guys
we want souls
souls is when you don't never have to
initiate contact with a woman
but she'll initiate contact with you 100
of the time
how many of you guys think you're going
to get that complimenting women
think about it all right you're not
going to get no [ __ ] like that what
you're going to get is
you're going to get a woman you got to
[ __ ] pursue all the time
and you're gonna be on here crying how
do i get her to initiate contact
because that's how women are when you
give them certainty that's how they act
all right they make you uncertain all
right
instead you want her chasing you guys so
that's hot
all the girls that are in my rotation
guys they initiate contact 100
so i'm just trying to imagine like
the the chicks in his rotation like
watching this video like
some of the time the girls that are in
my rotation
initiate contact 100 of the time that's
what you want you're not
gonna get that validating women you're
not gonna get that being a [ __ ]
dancing monkey on a date you only get
that
when a woman is obsessed with you which
comes from her chasing your validation
because you don't get
it all right guys but getting back to
the first point guys he wanted to know
why women come back to win guys after
they lie cheek disrespect them
guys women are not saying turmoil
women are emotional they get bored as
[ __ ] quick as [ __ ]
all right women are emotional but i'm
telling you it's up to a certain age
so any of you guys if you're looking at
your relationship and it's too
too good to be true it's too perfect no
turmoil some shit's gonna happen right
now
all right something's gonna happen she's
gonna start cheating on you she's gonna
start pulling back
she's gonna start getting bored she's
gonna try to create some turmoil
it's best that you create it now i'm not
saying you got to go lie and cheat on
the crit turmoil
i prefer you to be on your purpose to
create the turmoil
but regardless that's better than
giving a woman certainty all right
that's the thing with that guy that's
why women go back to guys who lie cheat
respect them it's
fun it's something to do women don't
like that ordinary boring ass picket
pick and fit [ __ ] they try to put on tv
that you guys think women won't they
don't like that
all right they'll take it from a better
man probably but then they're going to
be [ __ ] around on them every time
they
every chance they get guys that's the
way that works
all right guys i just i feel like the
people
okay this is a weird observation but i
feel like extremely hot
people are in like a different world and
this is why i know
that like the richest people the hottest
girls like don't have the happiest
relationships because like
watching like this type of content i'm
like
oh my god this is why hollywood everyone
gets married like three times
but i'm getting tired
let me know in the comments if i'm right
or if i'm wrong also
let me know if you think that is correct
do you think that
women like
chaos or do you think that women at a
certain age
want to settle down and find like a
stable reliable partner
either way don't forget to like comment
and subscribe